au fait une chaleur mais une chaleur une
chaleur à crever il fait 33 33 degrés
dans la partie pas possible ok alors il
est temps de vous dire ce que je pense
du nothing phone je voulais montrer
l'autre jour je les aime boxer chevalet
la conférence à londres j'ai regardé
j'ai tout vu et j'ai un avis cucugnan
voilà je vous le donne et on va se
parler aujourd'hui de l'os iphone c'est
l'heure de se dire un peu est-ce que ce
smartphone intéressant c'est un peu le
smartphone de la haye pour autant
faut-il acheter faut-il se positionner
faut-il aller dessus s un smartphone qui
va être intéressant un temps va-t-il est
réellement intéressant on y va vous êtes
prêt vous allez tout savoir sans nos
segments
[Applaudissements]
ok alors première chose à faire l'idée
c'est de revenir pour resituer un petit
peu le concept lors j'enlève ma coque
transparente qui est hyper cool le
nothing phone c'est ça c'est un format
c'est surtout un design un peu différent
par rapport au reste du marché l'idée
d'une hausse et phone c'est un design
très a pas on est sur un smartphone
milieu de gamme sur android jallet
tarifs je vous la donne en or si tu
version 828 469 euros 8 256 499 12 156
549 on est donc sans du milieu de gamme
android expérience quasiment stock
expérience pure il ya eu des vrais choix
qui ont été faits notamment idée d'avoir
un design avec un écran oled flexible
non pas pour le plier mais tout
simplement pour permettre d'arriver en
bas et de ne quasiment pas avoir le
manteau et d'avoir une vraie symétrie
parce qu'un vrai choix au niveau du
design donc c'est un smartphone que je
trouve vachement bien design et que je
trouve intéressant voilà non super bien
design est hyper canon qui à défaut
their d'apple mais ça je pense que voilà
tout ça vous aura sauté aux yeux à
l'arrière je trouve pas nécessairement
parce que c'est joli carrière pas
nécessairement parce qu on a vraiment
souhaité transparence et par rapport à
un iphone c'est quand même un peu autre
chose mais voilà il est sympa il est
dans l'air du temps ils marchent bien et
je pense qu'ils sont à vous car donc
d'un point de vue design il est super
beau vraiment super beau maintenant on
est sur un smartphone sur android milieu
de gamme pas plus à moins il fait le taf
il le fait bien mais le vrai intérêt et
est-ce que c'est pas un peu ce qui
pourra aussi vous lasser dans le temps
j'en sais rien c'est qu'on appelle la
griffe interfaith c'est à dire ceux
d'eau qui est très différent et qui est
hyper sympa alors on va reprendre un peu
l'histoire je vous restitue le truc
regarde vous prenez vous allez dans vos
paramètres dans vos paramètres vous avez
l'interface glyphes ici vous pouvez
venir les activer ou désactiver bien
évidemment activé ce qui nous intéresse
ici donc ça vient actionner quoi des
couleurs sur différentes zones et
lumière sur différentes zones alors pour
l'allumer en permanence les petites
astuces à connaître vous venez dans
votre appareil photo vous faites comme
si vous voulez mettre le flash et là
vous l'avez tout est allumée donc vous
avez 3 hall vraiment différente le petit
c qui vient entouré l'appareil photo
espèce de petite virgule en eau
legranger comme greu et oui qu'on va
retrouver ici et le petit point
d'exclamation en bas l'idée c'est que
tous ces éléments travaillent ensemble
vont permettre d'avoir différentes
combinaisons que ce soit pour des
sonneries que ce soit pour différentes
sûrs de garder jeudi que l'attaqué et je
l'enlève donc ça c'est rigolo et ça ça
vous permet quoi hop il part à m ça vous
permet de venir notamment pour les
sonneries regarder up pour les sonneries
d'avoir des combinaisons un peu
différente météo plat c'est ça
j'en mette un peu de sens pour vous
puissiez entendre en même temps voyez
vous avez des sont à la fois
électronique vous avez des combinaisons
différentes et le truc est hyper canon
avec moi j'aime bien il faut vraiment
intéressante saïd et se dire votre
smartphone lorsque vous posez sur une
table je me remets sur celui que j'aime
bien c'est un peu long et stressant mais
ça fait partie du truc donc ça
j'enregistre est l'idée qui est cool
aussi c'est que lorsque vous prenez
votre smartphone et que vous le posez à
l'envers et à plat ou prenez vous le
retourner et en fait ça vous le mets en
silencieux et pour voir cela bien
activée ça vous fait apparaître les
petites lumières comme on a vu tout à
l'heure donc là vous savez qu'il est en
silencieux que maintenant si vous
recevez un coup de fil par exemple de
votre votre amoureux et amoureuses vous
pouvez avoir par exemple que le sait qui
est là si vous avez votre boss qui vous
appelle ça peut être que le point
d'exclamation peut venir personnalisé ça
et c'est marrant on peut le faire en
fonction de chaque personne qui va vous
appeler donc on peut venir complètement
personnaliser l'expérience donc ça c'est
marrant regardez au xénon sonneries et
vous venez ajouter un contact contact
personnalisé alors attendons pas m hop
là je mets horoscope et là par exemple
pour horoscope je peux mettre mes
propres sonneries bon alors je vais
mettre mes différentes combinaisons
alors après pour autant je peux pas
vraiment en faire ce que je veux comme
je veux mais voyez par exemple en face à
tetris mais ça peut être le petit point
d'exclamation lorsque c'est votre boss
qui vous appellent enfin bref il ya
différentes combinaisons et elles sont
assez marrante donc ça va dépendre
totalement de la personne voyez up 6 et
l'horoscope qui m'appelle ses tennis et
ça ça va dépendre de chaque personne
donc ça c'est expérientiel est ça qui
m'a en fait c'est l'expérience que vous
avez parce qu'en fait nothing ils font
quoi ils vous vendre concept qui vous
vendent une idée une idée qui est
marrante mais pour autant ils vont pas
venir révolutionner l'histoire autres
tout ce qui est rigolo lorsque vous
vivez le recharger alors mon blog de
charge je vais le brancher regarder
lorsque vous venez le branché il va vous
donner le niveau de charge également
vous voyez vous en êtes et vous allez
voir la progression donc ça c'est
marrant aussi ça je trouve ça
intéressant parce qu'ils ont fait ce qui
est cool c'est qu'ils ont données réels
intérêts au dos de votre smartphone qui
est à la fois hype et qui à la fois
design et mais qui est un vrai sens sur
les appels sur côté silencieux sur les
lumières ils ont fait un autre qui aussi
super intéressant c'est que lorsque par
exemple vous venez faire une photo et
bien normalement vous mettez voilà le
flash je m en vidéo vous verrez ce sera
mieux voilà vous avez le flash est sale
flash est très agressif et le flash en
fait ça a tendance à venir un peu
écrasée je vous le montrer dans la
partie photo l'a fait des tests via un
peu écrasé les visages ils ont fait ce
qui est très très intelligente justement
et bien vous avez ça ça qui vient vous
éclairer et ça c'est beaucoup plus douce
beaucoup plus doux et ça permet d'avoir
une lumière plus homogène est beaucoup
plus douce envisager ça écrase beaucoup
moins et pour les photos nues sa cfh
montmagny c'est extrêmement mal donc là
il ya un vrai usa ça marche super bien
et ça vaut pas mal entendu imposer de
vous la péter devant vos potes voilà
donc ça c'est rigolo donc ce côté là je
trouve marrant je trouve malin je trouve
ça fonctionne réellement et il ya un
vrai intérêt et une fois de plus je vais
vous montrer le côté photo tout à
l'heure après il ya un autre truc qui
est assez marrant lorsque des fins de la
recharge l'inversé que vous l'avez
active et hop regardez vous prenez vous
posez vos petits écouteurs sur le dessus
alors attendez à ce que je les
désactiver normalement non batterie
partage de la batterie vous autorisez le
partage de la batterie et lorsque vous
l'avez autorisé certains traitements
classiques vous prenez vous posez dessus
et vous voyez que le partage de la
batterie est lancée et vous voyez voilà
que c'est en train de charger moi j'ai
ma petite diode est en train de charger
mais ikhwan mes écouteurs dada fait donc
c'est cool une fois de plus donc en fait
le dos de votre smartphone que
normalement on vient cacher avec une
coque comme ici sur un iphone et bien
non il un vrai intérêt d'un intérêt
esthétique mais au-delà de ça au delà de
la griffe hunter fait ce qu'on a
derrière qu'on peut venir paramétrer
qu'on peut utiliser comme petites
lumières lorsqu'on veut faire une photo
ou une vidéo au delà du côté recherche
inversée au delà du côté gadget et au
delà des sonneries un petit peu
particulière un peu années 80 et bien le
reste du smartphone à smartphone milieu
de gamme c'est un bon smartphone milieu
de gamme attention ça très bon
smartphone milieu de gamme ce café
nothing ici c'est au fait de vous mettre
un dark thème vous pouvez venir changer
un sans aucun problème vous retrouvez
les polices de nothing sa police
d'écriture qui est un peu tous les côtés
mais sinon c'est un très bon smartphone
milieu de gamme android et qui marche
bien avec juste les petits paramètres
pour la griffe interfaith et c'est tout
et c'est bien et c'est bien à tomber
parce que si vous voulez du landry pur
vous avez de l'android tueur c'est
vraiment l'idée et on a un très joli
smartphones et que je trouve très cool
et ils essayent aller pareil devant
monter une nouvelle histoire guérilla
tout l'expérimental avec fait de pouvoir
venir connecter votre tesla bon ok ça
c'est des choses qu'on retrouve un jeu
dire ces choses qui existent déjà mais
voilà l'idéal est là c'est un très bon
smartphone sur android avec un bel écran
avec un taux de rafraîchissement de 120
hertz adaptatif on a tout les specs qui
vont bien matériel tout ce que je peux
dire un peu reproché c'est lorsque je
suis venu faire quelques photos je
trouve que des fois le déclenchement est
un petit peu long après on est sur du
milieu de gamme on est sur un snapdragon
778 j'ai plus grave est aussi à nommay
tsedu t.snc ça marche bien en faible
luminosité j'appuie ça déclenche pas
tout de suite et lorsqu'elle la lumière
des fois baladant léger mille flight ont
pas forcément ça me fait un peu le bazar
mais je trouve que des fois c'est pas
toujours hyper hyper réactif non mais
voyez là ça marchera ya de la lumière
c'est leur équipe surtout qu'est ce cas
c'est assez peu lumière ou un peu moins
de lumière mais le rendu globalement et
là je vous montre les photos je suis
venu faire avec le résultat est là iris
est sans appel ça marche bien regardez
on peut venir un switcher entre
différentes photos ça c'est la
conférence le seul truc que j'aime pas
trop ici c'est du très grand temps que
je trouve qu'une vraie grosse différence
de colorimétrie auteurs vachement sur le
jeune beaucoup trop sur le job regarder
le ciel regarder les bâtiments par
rapport à là c'est beaucoup trop jeune
et je trouve que le traitement l'aï pas
très joli très honnêtement c'est
beaucoup trop jeune on peut venir ou non
un peu mais comme ici vous avez
uniquement un grand-angle un ultra grand
angle et bien le zoom sera numérique x 2
ça marche au delà on vient dégrader la
qualité donc regarder globalement ça
fonctionne ça fonctionne plus très grand
temps que c'est un peu moins fan mais
voilà alors petit défaut au niveau de la
caméra de celle fille ça vient un peu
trop lisse et je trouve que c'est pas
très très très joli mais ça il ya
beaucoup de constructeurs qui font ça
aujourd'hui mais sinon dans l'ensemble
ça marche le mode portrait non
merveilleusement bien coup quoi titouan
de frandroid d'ailleurs qui a gentiment
posé pour moi et donc non ça machecoul
année également du journal du geek le
mode portrait est vraiment superbe voilà
donc là-dessus il n'y a pas de souci si
ce n'est cet ultra grand-angle que je ne
trouve pas beau alors après une mise à
jour peut venir corriger ça il faudrait
d'ailleurs mais sinon dans l'ensemble ça
fonctionne pas trop mal pas trop mal
autres photos nature garder un côté un
peu vert jaune c'est pas beau et
lorsqu'on vient zoomer zoom et zoomer
dézoomer non on va pas ou mai mais dans
l'ensemble sur le capteur principal le
job est fait le job est très bien fait
on peut faire de la macro sur l' ultra
grand-angle mais je suis pas convaincu
non plus un truc qui existent on peut le
faire un peu il faut trouver les quatre
centimètres je skie pas très évident bon
mais dans l'ensemble on a un smartphone
qui est très cool on peut venir s'amuser
sur le capteur principal c'est vraiment
le capteur principal qui est très bon et
en conditions de faible luminosité on
obtient des choses qui sont très sympas
très honnêtement que ça marche bien
qu'aucun copains on sort des résultats
qui sont vraiment chouettes et qui voit
la faune le taf sur un smartphone milieu
de gamme regardez ça c'est sûr c'est ce
que je voulais vous montrer ça c'est
l'éclairage que vous avez derrière sur
la griffe hunter fesses c'est pas mal au
niveau du visage ça c'est homogène on a
bien tout le reste lorsque vous mettez
le vrai flash ça écrase tout de suite ça
iqra savent où sort un visage qui est
vraiment pas beau et tout le reste
n'existe plus regarder la différence
c'est quand même énorme c'est et là pour
le coup ils ont vraiment fait un truc
très malin au niveau de la photo avec un
flash à la le flashy les hardcore le
flash regardez pareil sur anne là vous
avez avec la griffe interfaith et là
vous avez le flash le flash il écrase
tout s'est vraiment pas beau donc voilà
on s'est un peu amusés à faire
différentes photos de nuit à londres ça
marche pas mal j'en avais fait également
en concert on emmenait en voyant vite
devenir zoom et la nuit en concert on
voit trop rien mais dans l'ensemble ça
marche pas mal sur le capteur principal
très honnêtement ça c'est l'ultra
grand-angle on le voit la faune
s'ébruiter mais c'est normal attendait
sur le capteur principal le job est fait
ça fonctionne donc voyez qu'en termes
deux photos le smartphone s'en sort
quand même plutôt pas mal côté vidéo je
trouve qu'il s'en sort aussi plutôt pas
trop mal le job est fait regardez ce qui
est intéressant c'est comme on a une
stabilisation optique on peut venir
filmer ça bouge pas trop je trouve ça
c'est pas mal fichu quand même même la
regarder coq aux ânes a contrario on
voit que sur la caméra de celle fille et
lorsque j'ai filmé ben comme n'y a
aucune stabilisation ça bouge ça bouge
ça bouge donc me concernant va vite et
on vient le poser directement sur un
trépied mais le rendu est pas mal en
terme en terme d'image et puis une fois
de plus que je viens et mais est ce que
je trouve intéressant c'est qu'ici on
est stabilisé donc on arrive à sortir
des sentiers sont pas mal fichu voile à
niveau multimédia ça fonctionne l'écran
est bien très belle qualité haut
parleurs ici principal au parlant de
renforts son côté très grand classique
ça une fois de plus dans le milieu de
gamme donc on n'a rien à lui reprocher
si vous voulez lire vous amuser jouer à
des jeux si vous voulez venir visionner
des films des séries vous aurez ce qui
fonctionne sur un smartphone milieu de
gamme avec un bel écran oled pas de
souci si ça fonctionne c'est cool donc
en gros ce qui font venir tenir ici sur
ce smartphone ses côtés très ingénieux
au niveau de l'arrière avec la glyphes
interface un bel écran suffisamment de
performance il est ok en photo sur le
capteur principal de jour et de nuit ça
fonctionne on a de la recharge 33 watts
filaire même si vous avez un bloc de
charges 45 watts à ça reste un peu le
mystère du truc mais bon c'est comme ça
donc non il ya une belle expérience si
vous voulez un beau smartphone sur
android pas trop cher avec de bonnes
spec avec ce qui va bien en termes de
ram c'est à dire donner des technologies
en effet ddr5 vous avez un stockage en
fs trois points ça fonctionne on est
vraiment dans l'idée d'un très beau
milieu de gamme extrêmement atypique
avec un nouveau design donc s'il vous
plaît vous pouvez y aller les yeux
fermés il est très cool si maintenant
vous avez des doutes sur le design est
ce qu'il va être vieillissante fauche de
réactifs ça est ce que c'est un truc
dont je vais me lasser est ce que c'est
un truc qui va continuer à marcher dans
le temps moi je dirais qu'il ya un seul
truc à se dire en fait c'est que plus
design vous êtes ip plus les design vont
être forts et plus potentiellement on
peut venir se lasser on peut se dire ok
c'est joli ça a marché il y avait un
vrai truc un peu différent mais je
l'avais vu j'en ai soupé je peux que la
petite musique oscille pipi pilipili bip
c'est très drôle mais il se peut que
vous finissiez par vous lasser alors moi
aujourd'hui j'aime beaucoup j'ai un vrai
coup de coeur parce que je teste tout le
temps des smartphones et celui là est
très différent par rapport au reste du
marché donc c'est cool mais je me dis
qu'en ayant toujours un smartphone tous
les jours un smartphone qui fait bip bip
avec les lumières il se peut que j'en
sais rien dans un an j'en ai un peu
marre des bips bips j'en ai un peu marre
de la griffe interfaith je sais même pas
je suis même pas sûr que nos s'il
continue à garder la griffe interfaith
plus tard donc voilà un peu pour l'idée
est ce qu'aujourd'hui c'est un
smartphone que je peux vous recommander
la réponse est oui parce qu'ils écoulent
les canons ils se rechargent bien je fou
quand même bien acheter des trucs un peu
à part mais bon ça c'est pas nouveau et
pas le seul à le faire la marque une
jolie histoire le produit est cool il
est très bien positionné en prix et il
est chouette voilà ce que vous risquez
de vous lancer dans le temps la réponse
est très certainement oui voilà mais ça
c'est une autre histoire de toute façon
on peut toujours cela c'est donc au pire
vous mettez une coque et vous désactivez
la griffe interfaith et vous aurez
toujours un très bon smartphone sur
android dans le milieu de gamme sans
problème dit moi vous ce que vous en
pensez ce que vous pourriez aller sur ce
smartphone est ce que le fun one vous
botte est ce que la marque nocives ou
hype est-ce que vous avez déjà les
airois qui sont très cool hein dans le
pareil dans le milieu de gamme à très
cher un besoin de 100 euros dit moi tout
ça en bas en commentaire les deux
fonctionnent bien ensemble donc voilà je
vous laisse me dire ce que vous en
pensez mais on se retrouve très vite
pour continuer à parler de teck et de
plein d'autres sujets c'est très
intéressant je vous embrasse pour les
soins de vous il ya très vite bisous
[Musique]